bird box has finally arrived on Netflix
similar to the source material of the
post-apocalyptic film follows a woman
and her two children making a
treacherous journey in order to find
safety there's obviously a lot to unpack
from the film and throughout this video
I'll be breaking down everything that
you need to know about the movie as well
as its ending there will of course be
heavy spoilers so if you're yet to see
the film that I highly suggest that you
turn off now but for everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I ruin it so you don't
have to we follow Malory a mother of two
as she sets out on a perilous journey in
order to reach sanctuary the world is a
desolate landscape due to the invasion
of mysterious creatures that caused
their victims to commit suicide upon
seeing them
we never get confirmation as to exactly
what they are but there are several
theories that range from biological
warfare to demonic forces and it's even
possible that they could all just be
fictitious elements of a book that one
of the main characters is writing
however personally I believe that the
creatures represent depression and this
is why they cause their victims to
commit suicide the monsters are often
shown to be dark shadows that overwhelm
the characters and in the minor glimpses
that we get of them they clearly appear
as a black cloud several of the
characters are seen muttering personal
aspects of tragic moments from their
past and it's apparent that the
creatures are able to manifest in such a
way that living under the second becomes
agony for those who bear witness to them
Mallory's disconnection from both of her
children and the world in general too
could be representative of prenatal and
postnatal depression brought on by her
pregnancy the biggest signifier of the
monsters manifestation as depression
however is not confirmed by the people
that they affect but rather the ones
that they don't throughout the film
Mallory and the rest of the survivors
she incorporates with come across
several people who have not only
witnessed the creatures but also seemed
enlightened by them
these people were labeled as crazy
before the apocalypse but to me they
represent depression caused by mental
health issues these characters have
obviously faced their deepest and
darkest fears already and dealt with
them internally thus when they
encountered the monsters
they have nothing to fear as they have
already faced and come to appreciate the
worst aspects of themselves so when they
face the creatures externally instead of
internally they are able to embrace them
due to the realization that everything
that they thought was wrong with them is
now the way the world is and they are no
longer a minority forced to hide
themselves from others in order to fit
in perhaps this is why they seem so
desperate to force the unenlightened to
see their internal troubles externalized
and live in a world where they no longer
face fear or feel alienated the monsters
effect the eyes when they attack which
cements to me that they want people to
see the world in a certain way and those
who are not already adjusted to this
view will become a victim to it in the
same way that the crazies as they are
called had to overcome about within in
order to survive Mallory's arc - mirrors
this originally she finds refuge with
other survivors when her sister commits
suicide during the initial attack by the
creatures within the first wave mallory
seems completely closed off from the
world and is a very cold character until
she strikes up a friendship with another
woman who happens to be pregnant as well
mallory takes care of her friend's child
when she is sadly killed after the
survivors mistakingly let someone crazy
in who forced them to witness the
creatures however mallory really seems
unable to build a connection or
relationship with the girl under her
care she refuses to give either of the
children in her care a name referring to
them simply as boy and girl to me this
is in order to protect herself from the
potential information that the creatures
could use against her they clearly
target personal aspects of their victims
so in removing their names she is able
to put some distance between herself and
them however as the trio journey of the
river
Mallory's eyes are open to the fact that
they are children even though his sight
is restricted eventually they make it
upriver but are attacked on all fronts
by the creatures with the monsters using
vocal cues and calls to tempt the
children to take off their blindfolds
just as they are about to close in
Mallory screams don't take my children
away from me which causes them to
retreat slightly personally I believe
that they are no longer able to attack
the group because they have shared a
bond between them that would help ease
the depression this juxtaposes
group of characters that Mallory was
originally with as all of them suffered
loss in some ways with their partners
either being dead or missing
Mallory is now complete and able to take
care and become attached to something
which prevents her from becoming a
target in the end she reaches the
sanctuary which is revealed to be Janet
School for the Blind at the sanctuary
Mallory meets the nurse that treated her
during her pregnancy and introduces her
children by their names for the first
time the girl is named Olivia after her
mother and the boy is named Tom after
the man that Mallory fell in love with
during the apocalypse
Mallory sets the birds free from the
titular bird box which symbolizes that
she's able to finally let her children
fly from the nest which of course has
similarities to the story that Tom told
the children and that they were so
fascinated with it's a touching moment
and Mallory is able to finally watch
your children spread their wings and fly
safe in the knowledge that they will no
longer face the darkness and will be
able to embrace happiness so what did
you think of bird box personally I loved
the film and thought it had a lot of
depth to it so I'm quite surprised that
it's getting mixed reviews across the
board
I found it engaging well acted due to
its phenomenal cast and a film with a
lot more below the surface obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts on it so make
sure you leave them in the comments
below and if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and check out my
breakdown of this week's other big movie
Aquaman which will be linked at the end
this is a channel for people who are
heavy into horror so if that's the kind
of thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]